ray is on Facebook
why term life insurance instead of whole
life life insurance what's the
difference
term life insurance is just insurance
that's all it is it's like your car
insurance it's all you get you don't get
any money unless you die and so you
don't ever get any money it goes to your
beneficiary right the only way it pays
off is when you die don't when your car
insurance pays off you don't make money
on your car insurance your homeowners
insurance
that's pure insurance that's all it does
it doesn't have any gimmicks or bells or
whistles that has an investment built
into it or you can buy cash value life
insurance which includes whole life or
universal life or variable life now
here's the typical numbers okay the
typical numbers are four five dollars
you can buy as much term life insurance
on a 20-year level term as you can for a
hundred dollars buying cash value life
insurance per month so why would you pay
ninety five dollars more per month
because it builds up inside of it a
savings account called cash value it
builds up a savings plan so that then
later on if you close the policy they
will write you a check and give you your
savings back so you have you buy
insurance in a sense for five dollars
and you invest ninety five dollars out
of every $100 per month so why is that
bad
what's bad for a multitude of reasons
number one the rate of return on the
typical whole life policy is around one
percent about like your stupid savings
account at the bank and no one builds
wealth at one percent on a universal
life after all the fees now they quote
you a higher rate but after all the fees
your net is around four point seven
percent these are all documented numbers
and on a variable which has mutual funds
in it by the time the mutual funds get
through the
all the ways of the insurance company
what should have been a 10 or 12 percent
rate of return lends up looking like
about a 6% rate of return so they hit
you heavy with the fees if you want your
money out of your quote savings account
out of your quote investment there's
only two ways to get it one is cancel
your policy and lose your insurance or
two is borrow it no I meant you're going
to borrow your own money and pay them
interest to borrow money you put into an
investment well that's stupid but people
do it all the time and people that sell
this crap act like that's tax-free
return it's not tax free it's borrowed
money and you're paying in interest to a
more to an insurance company to get your
own stinking money but here's the worst
thing let's say you buy like a couple
hundred thousand dollar policy and you
pay into and you pay into and you pay
into and you pay into and finally it
gets past all these fees and there's a
hundred thousand dollars in there and
you die your cash value is a hundred
thousand your face value is two hundred
thousand you die you know what they pay
two hundred thousand they pay the face
amount what happened to your hundred
thousand that you paid ninety five
dollars per hundred dollars a month
extra to build up well we don't know
apparently they keep it so you have a
savings account with a lousy rate of
return that when you die they keep your
savings that's whole life life insurance
it is one of the worst financial
products in the world it is the payday
lender of the middle class without a
doubt and the people that sell this
stuff should be ashamed of themselves
it's absolutely horrendous it's just
it's sad and you know here's what's
really sad they are really good at
selling it
well term insurance you know your term
insurance gonna run out about the time
you die and your family is just gonna be
left with nothing oh and you know do you
rent your house or do you buy your house
you know you're buying your policy we're
buying your policy with whole life
if you quit paying it you know what
they'll cancel it you could paying your
term insurance they'll cancel it you
know you don't build up equity in this
you are buying equity after they picked
your pocket some of it builds equity
called cash value but you still lose it
all when you die and so it's absolutely
ludicrous the whole sales process and
you know here's the thing it's twenty
times more expensive for the same amount
of of life insurance and guess what the
agent gets paid their Commission on now
you paid their commission on premium so
the edging gets paid on 100 bucks or
than five bucks for the same amount of
life insurance and so what ends up
happening is people buy this crap and
they don't buy enough life insurance to
take care of their family and then they
die with these stupid but tiny little
whole life policies that are a tenth of
what they ought to be so you want to
have about 10 to 12 times your income on
you meaning if you make $50,000 a year
you ought to have five hundred six
hundred thousand dollars in life
insurance on you you die your spouse
takes that and invest it if they make
eight or ten percent then they're
creating $50,000 a year and you've been
replaced that that lump sum investment
will pay your family what you used to
earn before you died and it's that
simple and you know it just doesn't cost
anything term life insurance is very
very inexpensive to get the proper
amount and this is why I have endorsed
Oh endure endorse term life insurance
from the very first day I turned on this
microphone 25 years ago and why have
endorsed Sander insurance to get your
term life insurance because they shop
and get you the best possible price
they're great folks they do a great job
of taking care of the customer I
personally buy my insurance of xander
but whether you buy it they're not never
by cash value insurance it's absolutely
an antiquated crappy product and it's
all about them making money it's nothing
about you making money
that's what I mean by being the payday
lender or the middle-class it's just
horrendous so I hope that helps your Rae
go to Xandar insurance com get you a
quick easy quote on that term and that's
what you ought to do what I do and it's
what I've done virtually my whole life
yeah
there you go this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show so you have to break the cycle
you have to flip this thing on its head
and make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind